these onions look real nice and crunchy
peanut butter looks real nice and creamy
bread looks real nice and fluffy i think
we're in for a texture ride
[Music]
today we are going to be trying some
very interesting sandwich combinations
but i don't know what that means i also
don't know what that means i'm a little
nervous about this taste test because
once we came to the table i saw this
bowl yeah for spitting so yeah i don't
know how gross this is going to be break
it off
[Music]
i like bread i like bananas i like
mayonnaise i don't typically put all
three in the same thing it already just
smells like i don't want to eat it
cheers cheers
little cheese
[Music]
you just dove right in oh
i'm good
yeah i'm not spitting it out or anything
no i can do with it it's not something i
would make at home
just mayo can only be on so many things
and mayo with banana is just not one of
them
can we have water oh i got the
goosebumps um i feel like the mayo
overpowers everything if i focused on
only one of them at a time it was okay
but
something about just like the banana
like surrounded by mayonnaise that was
that was not good
so many things could improve this one
being they're not being male in the
sandwich i would toast
the bread
to add some crisp to it nice crunchy
texture to it to kind of balance out the
softness exactly everything in the
inside some texture i think the mayo has
a tanginess and then the banana has a
little sweetness and i mean wonder bread
is wonderful if i was really hungry i
would again put the bananas on the side
and i would just eat the bread mayo and
then
after i'll eat the banana as a dessert
it's gonna be a no for me it's a no
mmm it's like a grilled cheese yes i
don't know why this would be weird oh
but wait what's wrong with it oh
oh there's something in it hey banana
oh no
i'm not too opposed to it it's good
actually this isn't too weird to me it's
just a fruit inside of grilled cheese i
can see this one being a thing yeah
i like it i don't think they necessarily
go together but i also i'm not grossed
out i think the flavors all work really
well together but to whoever made this i
have a hot tip for you don't grill it
with the bananas in there i think if you
had a cold banana the contrast between
the hot and the cold with the flakiness
of the bread would be
really good i think this person got
really bored one day and just thought a
grilled cheese is too plain he wants to
spice things up so then they put banana
in it if somebody made this from you and
offered it to me i would be like thank
you yeah it inspires me to make it at
home now so i would remake it with my
own recipe i think i actually might try
this like on my own like with my own
variations maybe like a lighter cheese
this is thumbs up for sure yeah two
thumbs up agree
i don't know what that is i don't know
what that is it's onion i'm really
scared right
onions
okay
these onions look real nice and crunchy
peanut butter looks real nice and creamy
i think we're in for a texture ride you
are so optimistic about what is clearly
about to be a bad time
[Music]
i mean i bit into it and i was like yeah
peanut butter sandwich here we go and
then the onions showed up
at first you're like oh this isn't that
bad like it's just like oh crunchy
peanut butter sandwich i love peanut
butter and then you get down into the
depth flavors of the sandwich and then
it hits you with the onion
this combination is fine with me i
wouldn't do it on my own i mean it's
edible none of the sandwiches were like
awful to the point that i couldn't eat
and spit it out
so yeah it works i would not eat this
again thumbs down i wouldn't try this at
home i wouldn't make it again i'm sorry
not not a big fan of this one
just one thumb
this was an experience
yeah it was very strange what what are
your like what's the order of your
favorite least favorite grilled cheese
is definitely my first cheese is number
one the favorite was the grilled cheese
and the banana my number one is male and
banana i want to say the onion one's
gonna be first
number two i think onion and peanut
butter i would say the peanut butter and
onions i would agree and number two is
onion and peanut butter but my number
three is that is that banana mayo one
not okay it's cold yeah it's just purely
a mayo sandwich on that one my number
three was cheese and banana which was
still good i just think really missed
the mark on the contrast in temperature
this was a restaurant i would not come
back
i've had a pleasure dining with you may
i please have the check
[Music]
you